Hey guys I brought you back out to the mountains today
Because I want to show you another cool way
You can start a survival fire using a sandwich baggy
Now over the years I've shown you how you can use water to start a fire
Using things like bottles, lightbulbs, saran wrap and even your pee
But I wanted to focus on using a snack bag today
Because there's a good chance you'll have one of these if you ever get lost while you're camping or hiking
Now perhaps one of the most important things in starting a fire is your tinder
The type of tinder that you use. We want to find something extremely dry
And I'm gonna be using some bark, I'm gonna crush this up into a powder
Cause contrary to my other videos would have you believe using paper to light a fire's not very easy
What we're gonna do is use these big rocks and smash that up into a little powder
Because the finer we can get this the easier it will light off with the rays of the sun
So after crushing this bark between rocks for a couple minutes
You can see it's been reduced to a really fine dust like a really fine saw dust
And the darker the wood color the better because it's gonna absorb more heat
and now that we've got this stuff we can move onto
our final few preparations before we actually light it up
A nice flat piece of bark like this would be good for a base plate
Then once we've got that in place we can just transfer the dust over into it
and form a little pile
and it's a good idea to have a backup
because as the embers and coals start building
you're gonna want to have some extra dust to sprinkle on there and build it up a little quicker
Now I got my little buddy out here helping me today
He's going to be gathering some of the twigs that we're going to use for our kindling
You can see that the ground is covered with all kinds of little twigs
and we want the thinnest ones possible
because that's what we're gonna transfer our embers to once we get a flame going
Trees are a great resource for kindling as well as they've got these
old, dead branches that are super thin, super fine
Within a matter of seconds you can get a whole handful of tinder
that'll just be great for when a flame starts growing
Now the last thing that's going to be really helpful in building a tinder bundle
is some kind of dead grass like this yellowish stuff down there
If you dig down underneath and pull it out
you can get enough of it to fold it over and build a nest
and our little sticks and twigs should nestle down nicely right inside of that
Alright guys, so I've been scavenging in the forest
for all the different materials that we'll need
then we got them laid out here in order
I'll be starting with this little tinder pile here
Once we ignite that with the sunlight I've got a little bit
coarser bark that I've ground up that we'll sprinkle over the top
Once that's smoking pretty good
we've got some dead grass that I can form into a little nest or tinder bundle
and once that catches fire, we've got little tiny twigs that'll help sustain that flame
and then hopefully that'll be enough
to catch these on fire
Once there's enough heat to ignite these things
our fire should be pretty well self-sufficient at that point
Now the trick to using a sandwich bag or a snack bag
to starting a fire
is first you gotta make sure it's empty
then you gotta fill it up with water
Now you're gonna want to fill your bag up about half full of water
and you can use water from a creek like I'm doing here
or water from your bottle
or in extreme emergencies you can even use your urine
The first thing you're gonna want to do
is tilt your baggie to the side so it makes a diamond shape
with one of the points facing down
Then we're gonna grab this top area here
then we'll need to twist that
to trap as much of the water inside as possible
Now the more you twist your baggie
the more you're gonna notice it starts to bulge out
and form these curves
which starts to look like a liquid sphere
and that's exactly what we're going for
It is a very fine line though
because the more you twist
the closer the bag is to bursting
and then you're gonna lose it all